petit voyage dans le temps également
voici ce à quoi ressemblaient les
imprimantes qu'on a bien connu noir et
blanc eh bien on va vous présenter
maintenant l'avenir et ce n'est plus de
la science fiction
il ya des médecins du centre
universitaire de santé mcgill qui
peuvent maintenant fabriquer des pièces
de rechange pour les humains avec une
imprimante 3d
vincent maisonneuve le dentiste maxime
champagne est un vétéran dans
l'utilisation de l'impression 3d
aujourd'hui il doit remplacer une
couronne de céramique abîmé d'un patient
de la vague australienne faveur de ce
culte
après avoir scanné la dent endommagée le
dentiste ont créé une nouvelle
parfaitement identiques seul est ce que
ce résultat final on va travailler avec
soin par donateur
l'information est transmise à
l'imprimante en moins de 15 minutes
la nouvelle dans est prêt
la technologie coûte près de 200 mille
dollars
mais le dentiste réduit de moitié la
durée du traitement
j'en avais rentable parce qu'on retrouve
des rendez-vous ont contracté de la
place tout n'est pas simple et on rentre
aux arçons de légers parce que sinon on
aura plus deux plages deux fois deux
heures pour faire un courante
si l'impression 3d est de plus en plus
répandue en médecine dentaire un groupe
formé de chirurgiens et d'ingénieurs du
centre universitaire de santé mcgill
souhaite intégrer l'imprimante 3d dans
les salles d'opération
certains rôles le docteur la chapelle et
chirurgiens cardiaques avec l'imprimante
3d
il pourra bientôt prendre l'image du
coeur de patients et imprimer une
réplique exacte en trois dimensions avec
tous les défauts les particularités et
puis après son secret sur le modèle au
lieu de ceux pratiqués se passer pour
l'enseignement c'est excessivement
efficace et évidemment pour le patient
ben quoi de mieux que d'avoir une équipe
que de jeu pratiqué sur ton corps et qui
a déjà évalué
les endroits problématiques le dr weber
et lui chirurgien orthopédiste au crédit
pointe nous offrent aux asturies cru
l'imprimante 3d va lui permettre de
replacer une vertèbre malajube brisée
par une copie scène parfaitement
identiques des traitements qui
espère-t-il devrait être disponible dans
deux ans à rennes vincent maisonneuve
radio-canada monde